[Music]  all right  my neighbor's passed out on the floor  and i can't feel her pulse  does the little girl have any family  members we can contact  family members  i can hardly take care of myself this is  your responsibility  hey music i'm your sister  all she's got now is you  [Music]  hi there i don't know what i'm doing  music it's your friend elbow  i live next door can you move in  she can understand everything you are  saying to her and if you are happy  press this very funny troublemaker  she sees the world in a completely  different way from us  we're about to have a full party  [Music]  you can do this  i'm gonna help her just like she helps  me  and i'm actually learning how to laugh  because i love her  [Music]  together  [Music]